[موسيقى]
كانت هناك مضاربات عنيفه في الاسابيع
القليله الماضيه مما نتج عنها ارتفاع
الدولار في السوق السوداء لارقام فوق ال
30 ويمكن حتى 36 ليست واقعيه ولا تعبر عن
القيمه الحقيقيه للجنيه فالمركزي قام بعده
همم يعني همم اجراءات لتصحيح الوضع ابرز
الاجراءات كانت تقييد حركه همم البيع
والشراء في السوق السوداء وايضا وضع قيود
على الاستيراد ويمكن اهم نقطه هنا هي
الوصول لاتفاق مع صندوق النقد وكمان تتم
الموافقه عليه كل هذا بالاضافه اللي طبعا
قرار زياده الفائده ساهم في تخفيض همم
الضغط
[موسيقى]
ايه ايه البنك ممكن يكون بيفكر فيه دلوقتي
مبدئيا كده يعني اشتراط صندوق النقد يعني
تطبيق نظام سعر
صرف مرن لا يعني اوتوماتيك له تعويم حر
ودي نقطه مهمه في ثلاث انظمه لاسعار الصرف
اما النظام اللي هو التثبيت او الوسيط او
المارينج وتحت كل نظام من الثلاثه فيه عده
اختيارات ممكن اي بنك مركزي همم يختارها
احنا عندنا النظام بالنسبه للي هو ال- ال-
البنك المركزي مش محتاج انه يعوم تعويم حر
عشان يكون نظام الصرف مارينت هو زي ما كان
قال محافظ البنك المركزي همم
ان احنا ممكن ان انا نربط همم العمله بسلم
من العملات من ضمنها اليورو مما يسمح
بتحرك الجنيه برده لكن مع ضمان تحكيم
للتذبذبات التي قد تنتج عن التعويم الحر
[موسيقى]